let me explain the reasoning that I use
when I look at a new layout it looks
like there's two equally spaced columns
here that signals to me that we need
linear layout weights where each of
these have equal weights so let's create
a horizontal linear layout within this
first child we have three vertically
stacked text views so we have a vertical
linear layout and the same goes for this
second child which has two elements
vertically stacked on top of each other
which means we use a vertical linear
layout as well and here's the code we
created a new list item forecast today
XML file under the layout folder the
code looks very similar to list item
forecast it has a horizontal linear
layout as a root element the first child
is a vertical linear layout with with
zero and a weight of 1 the second child
is another vertical linear layout with a
width of zero and a weight of 1 that way
the horizontal space will be distributed
evenly among each child if you go back
to the first linear layout notice that
we have three text views within it for
date high temperature and low
temperature we specify gravity to be
Center horizontal so anything within the
linear layout will be centered
horizontally otherwise by default they
would be left aligned to the linear
layout the same applies for the second
linear layout we specify gravity to be
Center horizontal so that the icon and
the weather forecast text view within it
are also centered horizontally